haley is in denver
hi haley how are you doing good thank
you for taking my call
sure what's up um my husband and i
um surrendered two vehicles back to
ford credit back in july of 2020
and our plan was to save up
a lump sum to cover the deficits
and hopefully pay it off within the next
year or so
they've already turned it over to an
attorney and we got a garnishment
letter um and we have a substantial
amount of other debts as well
so we're wondering if we should be
considering bankruptcy
or if we should try and crawl our way
out of this
okay let's back up a second there's no
such thing as a garnishment letter
uh there's a letter threatening a
lawsuit
in which case if they got the lawsuit
then if they win the lawsuit then they
could execute on the lawsuit
and then they could garnish which is a
six month to a year process
okay so the letter has come threatening
you
from an attorney is all right yes
okay all right does a garnishment notice
would have occurred
long after a lawsuit occurred and you
lost the law
suit which by the way you will lose
because you owe the money okay so that's
not a question
but um right so what is the deficit
balance with ford motor credit
um one of the vehicles was a ten
thousand dollar deficit and the other
one was fifteen thousand
okay and what's your household income
um my husband's a truck driver in the
oil field so
depending on the weather he can make
anywhere between
forty thousand and eighty thousand a
year
what do you think he'll make this coming
year based on the way things are going
today
um probably about 85 with my income
um because i make that's what is good
news
payment you make 40 to 50 as well
yes okay yeah okay and he'll make 60 so
you'll probably
go you're probably you're probably
shooting that low he's probably going to
make at least 60.
so um and he's going to work all in work
because you got a mess on your hands
so how much uh how much is your house
payment
22.50 per month um
what do you owe on the house uh we rent
okay what other debts do you have other
than this
um we have some tax bills state and
federal
totals about 11 000. okay um and we're
on payment plans with those
um and then we've adjusted our taxes so
that that doesn't happen anymore
smart um and then credit card debt we
have about 35 000
and then we bought cars cash
my parents helped us out with that so we
owe my parents about 8 000 and we're
paying them back on that as well
okay that's it yes
are you current on the credit cards or
are they in default
no we're current so the only problem
you've got is the threatening letter
from the lawyer
yes okay you might be bankrupt but it's
not for two more years
okay it's going to take that long for
this completely unravel and that's if
you do nothing
and instead i'm going to show you how to
save it okay
perfect it's going to be it's going to
be some sacrifice and some work but you
can do it
we're ready all right we need a change
yeah i can tell i can hear it in your
voice there's a there's a resolve
in your voice that's very powerful and
uh you've had you've had your i've had
it moment
you'd never want to be here again i can
hear it am i right
yeah we my husband and i want to adopt
the baby
and we can't do it like this nope you
can't you got a mess on your head i want
you to too but we're going to get this
mess cleaned up real fast
okay here's what we're going to do um
ignore the letter
they're gonna do nothing for right now
okay okay
number two i'm gonna put you into ramsey
plus
which is our full system on how to
handle money you and your husband and he
can do it while he's on the road because
it's all online he can follow along with
the classes with you
and you're going to take the financial
peace university class and you're going
to take rachel's know yourself know your
money class is now in ramsey plus
it's all free i'm going to give it all
to you free but you have to do
everything in there okay
okay and you're gonna get on a budget
and you and your husband are gonna work
on the budget together because it's on
an app
called every dollar and he can carry it
on his phone in the truck with him
and you guys can email and talk back and
forth and text back and forth and you'll
be working together even though he's
gone a lot
okay you gotta work together okay
okay he can't be out spending money
while you're trying to get this mess
cleaned up
you're both adults
is that going to work i'll have him
listen to this okay good yeah good
he can do it because he's not afraid of
hard work he just doesn't know what to
do
yeah i know him i grew up with him i
know guys like him i've known him my
whole life i love
i love truck drivers they're some of the
hardest working guys on the planet they
love their
families this guy works he's a worker
so he's a good man but he just doesn't
know what to do but now when we tell him
what to do dude you got to go do it okay
because i'm the guy that's i'm rachel me
we know more about this than anybody we
can show you how to do it all right so
now
so we we're paying the minimums on the
taxes we're paying minimums to mom and
dad
we're paying the minimums on the credit
cards and we're not paying the cars and
we're going to be on a tight budget
does that sound right so far yes
okay now what you're going to find when
you get on that budget is is you're
going to feel like you got a raise
because you're out of control with money
and everybody who's not on a budget is
out of control with money
and everybody who gets on a budget feels
like they got a raise
you're going to feel like wow where the
flip is all this money been going
you're going to have that thought and
that would be a normal thought be ready
for it
okay and rachel one of the one of the
videos
immediately when you sign up for ramsey
plus is going to be rachel showing you
how to do the budget
yeah the budgets can be powerful for you
haley i mean honestly when you start to
work this plan and you actually know
okay this is our income and this is
where it's going because then you can
look and say okay
you're going to cut out a ton i mean you
guys make a good amount you make good
money
and you can clean this up yes okay so
now we're paying minimum payments and
when we find money from working extra
and spending nothing you're not going to
see the inside of a restaurant
and you're not going on vacation you're
broke you're going to be doing nothing
but getting out of debt
and eating beans and rice rice and beans
okay okay better in bankruptcy
yes yeah i don't i don't want to have to
do that all right
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to list all of your debts the 8
000 11 000 and the different credit
cards that are
in total of thirty five thousand
smallest to largest it's going to be a
dinky butt little credit card
it's gonna be your little one you're
paying minimums on everything and you're
gonna put all the money you find on that
smallest debt
boom it's gone because you got a little
235
credit card don't you yep
knock it out couple of them we're going
to knock a couple of those out that's
going to feel good isn't it
first time you've made any dead gun
progress in a long time
it's going to feel good you're going to
feel powerful because you are you're
going to do this i can tell
i've done this for 30 years i can tell
when somebody's bs in me when somebody's
ready and you're ready
do you think that we can get through all
those deaths before
anything happens with the garnishment on
the vehicles yep
because you're not they're not going to
surprise you one day with a garnishment
they're going to sue you
and you're going to lose the lawsuit and
that's going to take two or three or
four months
during that time we're gonna stop
everything and pile up some cash
and they will take about 20 cents on the
dollar
okay so you can settle that 10 grand for
about two you can settle that 15 for
about three okay but you gotta have the
cash in your hand to do it
and you gotta be mean to them because
they're jerks
yeah i called them on monday and tried
to offer them a lump sum they
they wouldn't take it yet but maybe in a
few months they will yeah they'll soften
up and besides that they won't take it
in the first conversation anyway they
just want to see if you're going to call
your mama and get 80 grand out of her
yeah they're trying didn't you have a
reality that'll help you with this
you know do all that crap right are you
a deadbeat don't you pay your bills are
you not an honest person i mean you get
all these stupid butt conversations from
these collectors
don't put up with them you can do this
all right we're gonna
walk walk you out of this say i'm not
bankrupt say it over and over because
you're not
and we're gonna show you how to win
kiddo you call us back
if you need help anytime because it's
going to be a scary hard process
but you're going to do it 18 months from
now you're going to be
really close to being free that's my
prediction
two years from now you will be free